this is very good but I might not like
what this tastes but I'll eat it that's
different than it choking me and me
dying
you got your we we spent six million
dollars for this ad we're gonna stop
this ad and waste 4.3 million dollars
actually we're going to waste eight
point six million dollars because when
waste four point three million dollars
right now in this commercial how are you
I'm nicely hello how are you hello
I believe in passion and optimism and
pushing yourself but I
disproportionately believe in
practicality patience and hard work -
and they seem to be at odds with each
other
[Applause]
I'm actually really want to but we
cannot do because of the
responsibilities and you know we have to
do something because we have to double
up the question is what are we doing
something that you actually love so it's
a really interesting question and as I
was listening and I hope people paying
attention most people spend money on
dumb things which then forces them to do
things they don't want so step number
one for most people in here they should
sell their own take the money and go
read
they should return their BMW and get a
Toyota and that's why and honestly that
becomes the vulnerability why do you
want to BMW so to me that's where it
gets interesting right
do you or do you like what the brand
does to make you look to other people I
don't know I'm not assuming I don't know
I know I have a point I don't know you
but I know in the macro that 98% of
people that buy a Mercedes or BMW likes
what it makes other people think of that
not that they like it and that 487
dollars a month versus what they really
need which is a hundred dollars a month
is why they have a job they hate because
they're paying for a life that means
nothing the amount of people in here
that have a job they hate and they buy
things they don't care about to impress
people they don't give a [ __ ] about
scares the [ __ ]
you're asking only cuz you want to have
a bigger market yeah I want to have it
be good market marketers well guess what
polish is not a very big language yeah I
know okay
so yes the answer is yes yes a good say
they want some wine you know I think let
me tell you a couple things what how to
prioritize how to pick what to do how to
do everything
I yes exactly a long time the first
thing is to do that the first thing you
have to do is pay attention to anything
that you're doing that is taking time
like watching TV or reading good weather
looking on the Instagram like you have
to you have to look at every hour yes of
course I'm running a 900 person company
that has four global offices I have I
produced content every day I post I
reply I do this and put what you'll
learn look but I didn't do all those
things when I was thirty like you have
to be patient the mother thing you have
to focus on the singing and marketing
you try to balance them thank you so
much I hope that's amazing to meet you
how are you uncle Gotti
I trust you 100% that's why I didn't
want to talk about it when I got here
yes how are you good to see you I always
think if it's one thing that I don't
like it versus I can't breathe yeah
those are two very different things
I'm this is very good but I might not
like what this tastes but I'll eat it
that's different than it choking me and
me dying yeah so you have to ask
yourself staying in the family business
is that killing you then you got to go
and become a guitar player or social
meet or whatever but if you have that
big of an opportunity you may want to
eat more [ __ ] for five more years I
ain't [ __ ] building wealth for my family
not even for me
and then still at 35 had more than
enough time in a very short period of
time you ready Matt for you understand
at 27 you're impatient that's it because
I promise you one thing you go and do
what you love and it fails and all that
real estate all your other friends who
did it make a lot of money you're gonna
be a 33 very upset
[Music]
[Music]
ripp enjoys building to the tipping
point then you read the nose no wonder
why these kids out drinking booze and
was [ __ ] of me research other better
things
[Music]
got called I just let it ring
[Music]